SOURCE OF FUNDING.
WE COULD USE IT TO REOPEN
NEW YORK CITY AND THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY.
THIS COMES AS A BOMBSHELL NEW
ARTICLE FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING THE U.S.
STATE DEPARTMENT HAS LONG BEEN
WORRIED ABOUT HER RESEARCH
FACILITY IN WUHAN PROVINCE IN
CHINA ACCORDING TO THE POST,
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS IN
CHINA "SEND TO OFFICIAL WARNINGS
BACK TO WASHINGTON ABOUT
INADEQUATE SAFETY IN THE LAB
WHICH WAS CONDUCTING RISKY
STUDIES OF CORONAVIRUS."
"WASHINGTON POST" IS REPORTING
THAT.
THERE IS NO FIRM EVIDENCE OF THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC ORIGINATING IN
THAT LAB.
THE QUESTIONS ARE MOUNTING.
HERE NOW WITH ANSWERS, SECRETARY
OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
I’VE BEEN READING THESE INTERNET
RUMORS, SAYING THAT’S A
CONSPIRACY THEORY MADE IN THE
LAB AND I’M NOT SAYING THAT
SAYING THAT BECAUSE I THOUGHT
OURS WAS 98% THE SAME GENETIC
MATERIAL AS OF MY READING BUT
I’M BEGINNING TO THINK THAT
THERE’S SOMETHING WE ARE MISSING
MISSING.
>> IT’S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
HERE’S WHAT WE KNOW, HERE’S THE
FACTS.
THE FACTS ARE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION, THEY
HAD ACCESS.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
DIDN’T GIVE AMERICANS ACCESS
WHEN WE NEEDED THEM AT THE MOST
TIMELY POINT IN THE PRESIDENT
TALKED ABOUT THAT TODAY.
AND WE KNOW THEY HAVE THIS LAB,
WE KNOW ABOUT THE WET MARKETS,
WE KNOW THE VIRUS ITSELF DID
ORIGINATE IN WUHAN SO ALL OF
THOSE THINGS COME TOGETHER.
ARE THERE STILL A LOT WE DON’T
KNOW.
THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
WE NEED TO KNOW ANSWERS TO
THESE.
WE STILL HAVE THIS VIRUS OUT
THERE.
HE TALKED ABOUT GETTING THE
ECONOMY GOING NOT ONLY HERE IN
UNITED STATES BUT IN THE WORLD.
WE NEED ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS AND WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY IN MANY OF THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO DO
ITS JOB MAKING SURE WE HAVE
TIMELY EFFECTIVE AND REAL
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT’S GOING
ON IN THE GLOBAL HEALTH SPACE
AND THEY DIDN’T GET THAT DONE
HERE.
>> Sean: THEY ONLY NOTICED A
VIRUS ON DECEMBER 30TH LAST YEAR
WITH PNEUMONIA LIKE SYMPTOMS.
WE ONLY CALLED IT CORONAVIRUS
JANUARY 7TH.
FIRST CASE IN THE U.S.
JANUARY 21ST.
TRAVEL BAN AND THE FIRST
QUARANTINE IN 50 YEARS IN THIS
COUNTRY TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
KNOWN CASE IN AMERICA.
NOW, DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
WON’T GIVE THIS PRESIDENT
CREDIT.
TO ME, IT’S INCALCULABLE HOW
MUCH WORSE THIS WOULD BE, HOW
MANY AMERICAN -- THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DID NOT GET THE VIRUS
IN EXPONENTIALLY DIE.
WHY DOESN’T HE GET THE CREDIT HE
DESERVES?
HE WAS BRUTALIZED FOR IT.
>> IT WAS A DIFFICULT DECISION
AND HE MADE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
CALL.
HE DID IN THE FACE OF A WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION THAT
SUGGESTED THAT SUCH A
RESTRICTION WAS UNNECESSARY.
WE KNOW THAT IT BENEFITED THE
WORLD AND BENEFITED AMERICA.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY LIVES.
YOU WILL RECALL THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DECLINED TO CALL
THIS A PANDEMIC FOR AN AWFULLY
LONG TIME BECAUSE THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY DIDN’T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN.
WE NEED A HEALTH ORGANIZATION
IT’S GOING TO DELIVER GOOD
OUTCOMES FOR THE WORLD AND NOT
DO THE BIDDING OF ANY SINGLE
COUNTRY.
WE NEED ACCURATE INFORMATION,
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION.
THE WORLD DIDN’T GET THAT.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHEN THE HEAD OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WENT ON THE
ATTACK, I WAS LIKE REALLY?
YOU FAILED THE WORLD, THAT U.K.
STUDY I’M SURE YOU SAW, 95% OF
THIS COULD’VE BEEN PREVENTED,
YOU SET ON THIS SHOW YOU’VE GOT
A CALL FROM CHINA, YOU SAID WILL
HELP YOU ANY WAY WE CAN.
IT’S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
WORLD.
WHY DIDN’T THEY ASK FOR HELP?
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING BEHIND THE
SCENES?
COULD YOU ENLIGHTEN US?
>> I CAN’T ANSWER THE QUESTION
ABOUT WHY.
WE ALSO KNOW ABOUT THIS SAME
TIME THERE WERE THOSE INSIDE OF
CHINA, MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO
TRIED TO TELL THE STORY AND WERE
SILENCED, THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY REQUIRED JOURNALISTS TO
LEAVE.
THEY SAY THEY WANT COOPERATION.
WE WANT THAT TOO BUT TO
COOPERATE COMING UP TO HAVE
INFORMATION AND DATA.
THOSE ARE THE ELEMENTS OF
COOPERATION AND WE STILL WANT
CHINA TO DO THAT, WE STILL NEED
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY
TOOK PLACE.
IS NOT JUST IN THE PAST THAT
THIS CONTINUES AND THE NEED FOR
THIS INFORMATION CONTINUES.
WILL HELP SAVE LIVES.
>> Sean: I KNOW WE HAVE ABOUT
40 SECONDS.
I HEARD WHEN THE PRESIDENT
DECIDED TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
CORONA CASE IN THE U.S. THAT
THERE WERE 20 SOME ODD PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT TRAVEL BAN.
NOT MANY PEOPLE AGREED WITH HIM
IF ANY.
WERE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
>> I NEVER TALK ABOUT INTERNAL
DISCUSSIONS BUT I CAN SAY THIS,
THE PRESIDENT MADE A DISCUSSION
WAS A BOLD DECISION, THE RIGHT
DECISION AND IT SAVED AMERICAN
LIVES.
I HOPE THAT WILL GET REPORTED
WIDELY.
>> Sean: I JUST GAVE YOU THE
STORY TO TELL THE STORY.
YOU WENT TO WEST POINT.
LAST TIME I THINK I SAID YOU
WENT SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I APOLOGIZE BUT YOU ARE NUMBER
ONE IN YOUR CLASS.